hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big update guys on crypto
currencies and especially i'm going to
focus on bitcoin ethereum dutch coin and
solana so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so we were waiting for
that uh it arrived as usual guys on the
crypto market very brutally so let me
hear i'm gonna spend some time uh to
make an analysis on the bitcoin and as
you guys know uh those cryptocurrencies
they usually move together i mean if
bitcoin is going higher everything is
following so then i'm gonna go quicker
on ethereum dot com and solana let's
start here on bitcoin so maybe some of
you know already discounting but i'm
gonna do it again with you guys very
quickly we start from the beginning
okay we're not gonna start from the
beginning but i i could start from the
beginning guys so one two three four and
we're doing a massive fifth that started
in deck 18. in this fifth we can zoom in
and i'm gonna start
you know just to make the counting here
so i think that one two three we are in
a big third wave that would probably go
to hundred hundred thirty thousand and
then we're gonna correct
and then we're gonna have
another fixed wave so this is my
long-term view so i think we have uh at
least
two strong moves up to come on the
bitcoin in the coming years now if i
zoom in i go back on the daily guys and
so as we think there's going to be a
rally we need to find some good entry
levels so here this cycle that started
last year is complete at 65 000. then we
had this bearish divergence guys
remember this pattern it's very
efficient market making high highs the
momentum
shifting lower this means the market is
out of steam so here it was kind of
predictable the market would crash and
then we were trying to find the rebound
so first we have a wxy correction as
usual during those corrections guys it's
not easy to label it you never know if
it's going to be an abc or wxy so the
difference is that abc's five three
fives in terms of waves a number of
waves and wxy is three three three so
whatever
both are corrective patterns and both uh
usually end up with a breakout so here
we had the breakout at this level of
course guys i told you that we are
bullish and i also told you that we're
gonna probably do it one two three four
five then correct doing an abc or a wxy
so this is the reason why i was saying
we're gonna go at least to forty two
thousand and maybe to thirty seven so we
went roughly between and then we have
this breakout guys that happened few
days ago
so this trend line
that shows us that this pattern is
complete so this abc is complete but at
that time we didn't know if it would be
a wxy so abc abc abc or
just a simple abc and we start again and
here we have the confirmation by
breaking out above
50 to thousands we make a new high
we stayed there for
more than 24 hours so the wxy correction
is off the table because the x wave
cannot go above the start of the w wave
so this will will not happen now so what
might happen is a third wave you guys
know that third waves are very impulsive
so i'm not sure where gonna be the
pullbacks here what we are going to do
in our on this code guys if you don't
follow us come there i do live trading
with gabrielle on the u.s stocks but
we're gonna start doing crypto very soon
i think maybe one more week so this
breakout occurs a bit too early for us
we would have liked to buy lower but we
would still enter we're gonna show you
what kind of crypto we're gonna choose
gabriel is an expert on about those
cryptocurrencies those smaller
cryptocurrencies what people call
projects
so yeah it's gonna be just very
interesting we're gonna try to pick up
the best ones we of course gonna buy
some bitcoin ethereum the classic ones
because they are looking very good so
let me finish the tier here on bitcoin
first so we completed the second left so
we're doing a third wave so guys what
can we expect you know we can expect a
one two three four five right so a bit
developing like here so let me put it in
the same color
bam same degree it's a minor wave bam
all right so this is what we can expect
so
it's it's a bit early guys i i don't
know of course how high the third wave
would go i don't know exactly
where the corrections gonna be what we
know is that usually second wave they
correct 61.8 percent retracement but not
in bitcoin in bitcoin is rather 2d 28.2
or 50
so here the first wave is starting i
think this is already a one actually
guys
because the c wave was complete here so
we have a one
two
so we are in the third of the third guys
so this might be very impulsive it might
be very impulsive you see here this is
the the low was on 22nd of september
this is the start of the third wave
right and we have already done one two
so maybe it's a one two it's too early
to say guys i don't wanna be confusing
here i generally don't know where uh
this would actually uh correct but
i think that we're gonna see again 52
000
i mean it's not even short it can be
very impulsive what we're gonna try to
do is we're gonna just buy because if it
goes lower we're gonna buy more but i
think that even right now it's a good
level to buy because guys the targets
are higher all right so we are talking
here about getting at
5046 maybe at best of 54 so we're
talking about 8 000 difference when
against that there is a 50 000 profits
on the table
so the best thing not to miss it is to
go now because the signal is now so this
is what we're going to do once again i'm
not a financial advisor but this is what
we are going to do and follow us on
discord if you want to know more let me
just conclude here so the third wave
might go to i don't know maybe hundred
thousand and then correction and then
fifth wave let's see but i'm pretty sure
the end of here will be bullish ethereum
guys this is i think a nice opportunity
because we are lower here you can see
bitcoin is leading the pack uh ethereum
is just behind guys and it's the the
level is attractive to me we are just
above the breakout guys
okay look the breakout occurred here
and we have a resistance here that was
support before so maybe we're gonna have
a small rejection something like this
and then we go lower higher or we break
out right away uh same thing as all this
area is good to buy so between
3600 and 2900
everything that is here is good to buy
to me targets are high as well guys as
you know ethereum is very popular right
now even maybe more popular than bitcoin
bitcoin is still the king but ethereum
you know they have a technology a bit
different
i'm not an expert so i'm just gonna do
tia here but my friends that know things
a bit better than me are telling me that
ethereum might be the future so i think
that the level is attractive and i think
that we might easily go you know just
visually to the 6 000 level
even maybe higher by next year 7 000 you
know something like this so it's a
attractive level to me
dutch kind of so this one guys as the
name states is not a coin that has a
technology that is that has been created
to develop anything
but uh it's a mean kind of uh
cryptocurrency you know people attracted
to this elon musk is tweeting about that
quite often
so the technicals are not as good as
bitcoin and ethereum
we don't have the breakout yet but we
can assume that the breakout would occur
because we have everything that is
positive on bitcoin
so
i think that those are lagging behind
because people don't really realize that
we are in a bull run i mean i might be
wrong of course but i think that people
are right now talking about it what
should we do and that the strong buying
flows would come in the game very soon
so dutch coin it would be safer to wait
for a breakout and maybe try to buy the
retest but as you guys know we don't
have that many retests on the crypto
market i think that right now is a good
entry level and you know just using a
stop
below the eight 0.18 level seems good
last one solana guys so this one is you
know some people say it would reach uh
the
ethereum market capitalization one day
that it's a serious competitor for about
this technology
so i'm just gonna stick to the ti guys
because this is uh what i'm
good at so
one two three four we on the fifth let
me change the color we're on a fifth
wave guys so we're gonna use fit
projections to find some
targets about the fifth wave
uh woohoo it's already way above targets
so this method won't apply here so you
can see this is a good example of when
fibs are not really helpful fibs would
have give us 105 as a target so we are
way above that we went to the third fib
extension level
so we won't be using this method on the
larger degree wave counting but we can
still apply the method on the lower
degree counting
you know it's still giving us some
indications so i have 430 as a level so
i think that between 300 and 430 is a
good level a good like i mean reasonable
area for a target on solana so times two
so basically hundred percent
on ethereum hundred percent on solana
and hundred percent on bitcoin that all
makes sense to me so this is my view for
the next six months one year the crypto
market being yeah basically taking
hundred percent i think it makes sense
we still have money in the economy let's
see what the global market is doing
nasdaq is doing better sp is doing
better a global sell-off would cause
some troubles
on the crypto market so we're gonna
monitor that and this is the only signal
we're missing to be full power on the
crypto market we just miss some bullish
signals on the major indices spy nasdaq
so go check my other videos that i did
uh before about that you're gonna see my
level so basically 440 on the spy is the
level we need to trade above to have all
the green lights for the crypto market
so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys